Gear for.
So,
um,
next Saturday,
December 2nd,
there's a big fight.
It's the rematch between Max Holloway and Josie Aldo.
You also have Alistair Overeem and Francis in Ghana on that card.
Whoa.
Henry.
So Udo and Sergio Pettis,
Eddie Alvarez,
and just engaging who?
Just those four fights,
right.
Their whole leash.
Shit.
Holy Shit.
I know a,
I talked about Holloway versus all though before.
Um,
what I like about this fight is first of all,
the first fight was very good until although,
um,
ran out of gas and Holloway took over.
Um,
all those camp was saying that going into that fight all had a leg injury,
which kind of makes sense because he really didn't throw many leg kicks,
but he also didn't throw very many leg kicks against Frankie Edgar.
I think the strategy for then for that fight though was that he was worried
about the takedowns of Frankie Edgar.
So he had decided to avoid being taken down.
One of the best ways to do it would be just to avoid kicking and just outbox
him.
And he did that very well in that fight and won a pretty clear unanimous
decision.
This is going to be a different fighter.
I mean Max Holloway is in his prime.
He beat Aldo the first time around isn't he?
And he's incredibly confident that going to be able to beat all the second time
all go though said that he had this leg injury and it prevented him from
throwing leg kicks but that it's better now.
And that's one of the reasons why he's excited about fighting Holloway again.
Now if that is the case and if though is in tremendous shape,
cause he took this fight on relatively short notice,
he did not get a full two,
three month training camp.
I think it was five weeks out,
maybe more.
I'm sorry if I'm wrong about that.
I'm not looking at it right in front of me.
But I know it wasn't a full camp cause I know it was supposed to be Frankie
Edgar,
Edgar got injured.
So all those steps in.
So we're going to find out,
we're going to find out if all can make the proper adjustments and whether or
not the ability to throw leg kicks is going to make a difference because all
those leg kicks classically in history have been some of the very best in the
game.
If you look at his fight with your Riaa favor,
it's one of the very best uses,
uses best use of leg kicks,
maybe in the featherweight division ever.
And just smash Uriah Faber,
his leg to the point where,
I mean it's one of the all time grossest and injuries and MMA.
Uriah,
his left leg was like twice the size of his right leg and how to do a bunch of
crazy therapy to recover from him cooling hyperbaric chamber.
And he documented it.
Your eyes.
He's such a cool dude.
He's uh,
I loved that he did this.
He,
he documented a lot of the injury online to show everybody like,
look how fucked up my leg is.
And that's all due at its best is although the same guy now,
I mean he's gone through 29 professional MMA fights at the highest level.
He's been a champion for a long time.
And you know,
he's had some wars.
The second fight with Chad Mendez was a war.
Of course he got stopped quick by Conor McGregor or the fight with Max Holloway
was a war.
I mean,
he's been through some,
some really tough fights.
Does he still have that same level?
You know,
we really don't know.
And we're going to find out,
hopefully we're going to find out from a of an inch.
I mean,
I don't know what kind of camp he was involved in,
like how hard he was training rather before he entered into camp for this
championship fight.
I'm hoping that he was in good shape and that's one of the reasons why he was so
eager to take the fight.
And we're gonna find out we're going to fly out Saturday night.
And that's very interesting.